Transcription: HİBA HIJAZI ŞEHAB
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Bienvenue dans le labyrinthe de la musique
qui est constitué de sons et de silences.
Vous avez apprécié le son,
et vous avez laissé le silence
chanter en vous
et vous avez applaudi pour vous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
La musique est l’art de combiner les sons
de manière à les rendre
agréables à l’oreille.
Toutes les personnes
qui pratiquent cet art
sont appelées des artistes.
En musique, on les appelle aussi
des instrumentistes.
Le pianiste joue au piano.
Le flûtiste joue à la flûte,
mais ce soir, j’ai envie de vous parler
d’un type particulier d’instrumentiste,
le chanteur.
À quel instrument joue le chanteur ?
Le chanteur joue de sa voix,
un instrument particulièrement complexe,
parce qu’il fait partie de lui.
La plupart des instruments
sont composés de trois parties.
En l’occurrence, la flûte traversière
que je tiens entre mes mains
est constituée
de la tête, du cor et de la patte.
Tous les trois assemblés me permettent
de vous faire entendre plusieurs mélodies.
Le chanteur ou l’instrument vocal
est constitué de quatre parties :
la tête, le tronc, les membres,
et le plus important,
le psychisme.
La psychologie du chanteur.
On joue de cet instrument
à partir de ses quatre éléments.
Étant donné que la chanson ou le chant
est une extension de la parole,
cela signifie que le chanteur,
l’instrumentiste vocal est celui-là
qui est un athlète de la voix.
Devenir un instrument
nécessite d’apprendre
quelques rudiments de la chose.
Pour les cordes vocales, c’est un muscle,
un organe constitué
de muscles plissés mous
qui, avec la propulsion de l’air dessus,
les font vibrer à une certaine fréquence,
qui nous permettent d’entendre un son.
Et chaque son a une fréquence mesurable.
Vous convenez avec moi
qu’en plus des cordes vocales,
il faut une bonne maîtrise de son souffle.
La respiration est un élément particulier
et fondamental pour l'instrument vocal.
Et pendant le processus d’apprentissage
de l’utilisation de cet instrument
particulier qui est nous,
on nous apprend, ou alors on vous apprend,
on nous apprend à sentir
de manière ralentie, détaillée,
chaque événement qui nous fait vivre.
En commençant par notre respiration.
La respiration est la somme
de l’inspiration, plus l’expiration,
qui donne la respiration.
Si je vous emmène dans l'instrument vocal,
on dira qu'il y a une inspiration buccale,
une inspiration nasale
et une inspiration mixte.
Et de même pour l’expiration :
expiration buccale, expiration nasale,
expiration mixte. donc,
respiration buccale, respiration nasale
et respiration mixte.
Après la respiration,
il serait bien de savoir que la musique,
qui est un art particulier,
a aussi son langage.
Son langage,
comme le français et l’anglais,
avec son alphabet particulier.
Au lieu de 26 lettres, il n’en a que sept,
do, ré, m,i fa, sol, la, si.
Avec ça, on construit
toute la musique du monde.
Mais il faut noter
que l’instrument que nous sommes,
comme tous les instruments, est constitué
des trois registres de la musique.
Le registre des graves.
L’instrument vocal de sexe féminin,
dans le registre des graves,
est appelé alto
et le masculin appelé basse.
Dans le registre medium ou moyen,
le féminin est mezzo soprano,
le masculin est baryton.
Dans le registre des aigus,
le féminin est soprano
et le masculin est ténor.
Eh bien !
On ne s’arrête pas là.
Maintenant, quand on monte
dans l’instrument vocal,
ces différents registres se divisent,
se subdivisent encore en deux.
Dans le registre des graves,
nous avons la voix de poitrine
[confus],
la plus grave de toutes.
Ensuite, nous avons la voix de poitrine,
celle avec laquelle nous parlons
naturellement.
Quand nous venons dans les médiums,
nous avons la voix mixte.
Après la voix mixte,
nous avons la voix de fausset
ou encore appelée voix de tête
chez les femmes.
Et dans les aigus,
nous avons la voix de flageolet,
encore appelée voix de flûte.
Et enfin la voix de sifflet.
Pour faire résonner cet instrument,
maintenant que vous connaissez
ces registres,
nous avons besoin de connaître
ce qui fait retentir le son.
À l’image de ces baffles,
de ces haut-parleurs qui vous font
mieux m’écouter,
le chanteur l’a à l’intérieur de lui.
deux types de résonateur.
Le premier, la cage thoracique.
C’est le grand baffle,
parce que sur les baffles,
on a le grand baffle généralement.
Et ensuite on a les petits baffles.
Chez le chanteur, le grand baffle
de la cage thoracique :
si je fais un son simple “aaaaaah”,
vous voyez que c’est à l’intérieur
que ça résonne.
Et les petits baffles,
je peux pas les tester,
mais ce sont des résonateurs
au niveau de la face
qu’on appelle les résonateurs faciaux,
autour des lèvres,
au bout du nez, sur les pommettes,
autour des yeux,
au niveau des cônes frontales,
et enfin pour les très aigus,
la fontanelle, c’est tout ça
qui permet de propulser le son.
Mais qu’est-ce qui permet qu’on puisse
propulser soit très fort un son,
ou moins fort un son ?
C’est la force que nous avons donnée
à notre diaphragme,
qui est le muscle là par excellence
qui nous aide à la respiration.
Lorsqu’il est contracté, nous avons
l’inspiration et lorsqu’il est détendu,
nous pratiquons l'expiration.
Et ce muscle peut se travailler
en fonction du type ou de la catégorie
de musique que vous aurez choisi de faire.
Mais si vous êtes des orateurs,
vous aurez d’autres types de voix.
On parlera de la voix fluette.
Lorsqu’on parle très bas,
on n’arrive pas à parler très fort.
Mais à l’inverse, on aura la voix
tonitruante,
qui se fait écouter avec grande distance.
Nous avons aussi la voix monotone
qui ne relate rien,
qui ne traduit aucune émotion,
et nous avons la voix mélodieuse.
Distingués invités,
voyez-vous,
si je garde cette tenue-là,
vous aurez l’impression que wow!
vous avez en face de vous un super prof,
académicien,
qui a fait tous les conservatoires
du monde pour être là.
Mais si je vous le dis,
ce serait très faux.
« Yannick, c’est impossible. »
C'est comme ça que tout
a commencé pour moi.
Je n'étais pas un chanteur.
Je n'étais pas trop fan de musique.
Je n'y connaissais rien.
Ce n'était pas mon hobby favori.
J'en avais d'autres.
Jusqu’au jour où j’ai fait la rencontre
d’une jeune fille magnifique
et qui avait une voix sublime.
C'était mon premier amour.
Elle m'a emmenée dans son environnement.
J’ai côtoyé grâce à elle beaucoup
de personnes
qui étaient mordues par la musique.
Et j’ai commencé à aimer cette discipline,
comme je pourrais l’appeler.
Malheureusement, quelques temps après,
elle s'en est allée.
Ça a été un très grand choc, quelque chose
de très difficile à vivre
pendant son absence
parce qu’elle n’était pas décédée,
mais elle avait juste traversé
le continent.
Tout ce qu’il me restait,
était de réécouter la musique
qu’elle chantait pour moi
et qu’elle chantait
de temps en temps près de moi
et qu’elle voulait chanter
avec moi et ma voix.
Je vous le fais pas dire.
J'ai mis les pieds dans cette discipline.
J’ai été
près des camarades de classe
et je leur ai demandé conseil.
On m’a conseillé d’intégrer
des groupes de chant au lycée.
Déjà extrêmement timide que j’étais,
il m’était très difficile de me mettre en
face des gens et de produit quelque chose.
J’ai été chassé de deux groupes de chants.
Un autre ami m’a conseillé
d’aller à l’église,
parce que dans les chorales,
on apprend à chanter.
Et pour me motiver, il m’a dit :
« Même Céline Dion a fait la chorale. »
J’ai dit : « Ah?
R. Kelly a fait la chorale ? Wow !
Alors je vais à la chorale. »
Tout près de chez moi,
Il y avait une église catholique et moi,
j'étais chrétien protestant.
Je suis allé à l'église catholique
pour apprendre la musique.
Et le jour de mon audition,
mon chef de chœur n’a pas su
où me classer dans sa chorale
et m’a suggéré d’apprendre
à jouer au piano.
Pendant plusieurs mois,
j’ai essayé de chanter
en me rapprochant
du pianiste de la chorale,
et je recevais toujours autant
de critiques acerbes, de tomates et tout.
J’ai traversé beaucoup de moments
difficiles dans cette période-là
et je crois que c’est la période de ma vie
où j’ai compris que le mot motivation
était divisé en deux : motifs et actions.
Il me fallait un motif
pour passer à l’action.
Et ce motif…
était celui de prouver et de démontrer
c’est possible de faire
ce qu’on veut faire
sur cette terre, même si on n’y est pas
forcément prédisposé.
Et chemin faisant, j’ai fait la rencontre
d’un monsieur,
énorme, maître René Esso Elokan,
qui a été mon premier prof de chant.
Cette phrase que je viens de vous dire
juste avant est celle qu'il aimait dire.
Tout le monde est capable de chanter
de la meilleure manière du monde.
Si tu sais parler, tu sais chanter,
tu peux chanter.
J’ai avancé, j’ai appris dans le tas
que lorsque nous avions rêve,
il faudrait le chérir, le garder
et y avancer petit à petit.
Car à chaque fois
que je disais à quelqu’un
que je voudrais être un grand chanteur,
demain un bon chanteur
ou un prof de chant, on me disait :
« Toi, c’est impossible,
c’est mieux dans les arts martiaux
où tu es déjà connu, quand même.
c’est mieux de continuer là-bas. »
Et je disais : « Bon. »
J’ai avancé dans mon apprentissage.
Quelques années après,
mon prof de piano qui m’écoutait toujours
mimé après les cours de piano,
me conseillait plutôt de me présenter
à un concours international de chant.
Et là, j’ai dit : « Impossible, Yannick,
ce n’est pas possible. »
À la chorale et plus loin, on m’a toujours
dit : « Tu ne peux pas chanter. »
Et là, quelqu’un, pour la première fois,
croit en moi et me demande
d’aller me présenter à un concours.
J'étais déjà un garçon timide.
Et sur le chemin de la musique,
j’ai appris à être quelqu’un d’autre.
J’ai finalement présenté ce concours
et en 2005, j’ai été champion
d’Afrique centrale du concours Aguimucla.
La musique, elle fait partie de nous.
Elle habite en nous.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de planifier
un moment pour faire la musique.
La musique est utilisée aujourd'hui
comme thérapie.
Grâce à la musique, certains scientifiques
ont pu sortir des gens de leur coma.
Grâce à la musique, certaines personnes
ont guéri de leur handicap.
Des asthmatiques qui,
en pratiquant la flûte,
ont appris à contrôler leur souffle.
Grâce à la musique, nous gagnons
en confiance en nous.
Grâce à la musique, nous voyageons
à l'intérieur de nous.
Et c’est peut-être à cet effet
que Michael Jackson a dit :
« La musique est la bande originale
de notre vie.
Elle joue la mélodie de notre être. »
Distingués invités,
partant de nulle part,
quelques années plus tard, j’ai été le
chef de chœur de la chorale dans laquelle,
au départ, on ne savait pas où me classer.
Je suis aujourd’hui
le fondateur de trois entités musicales
qui vivent,
l’ensemble vocal Hot Voice of Sup de Co,
l’université dans laquelle
j’ai fait mes études
et qui, grâce à la musique,
m’a permis d’avoir
mes deux bourses de Master
un et deux pour avoir écrit
l’hymne de la diplomation
du Sup de Co Yaoundé.
Grâce à la musique,
étant dans cette même école,
passant sur les écrans de l’école,
une jeune fille m’a découvert :
« C’est qui ce mec qui chante ? »
Et ne voulant pas revivre la même histoire
que je vous ai raconté au début,
elle est ma femme aujourd’hui
et nous avons trois enfants.
(Applaudissements)
Voyez-vous, la musique
N’ouvre pas seulement des portes,
mais c’est parce qu’elle parle
cœur à cœur.
La musique est cet élément-là
qui nous permet de communiquer
avec des gens que nous ne connaissons pas.
Des musiques prient pour nous.
Je suis convaincu au jour d’aujourd’hui
que tous ici présents
avons pour premier amour la musique.
Quel que soit l’événement que vous voulez
identifier dans votre vie,
elle jouera forcément une musique
à l’intérieur de vous.
La musique, c'est la vie.
S’il m’était demandé :
« Qu’est-ce que tu peux
donner comme conseil à quelqu’un ? »
Je lui dirais : « chante. »
Je vous remercie.